the protesters are continuing to gather
in their tens of thousands outside the
prime minister's office
it's this growing pressure from the
street that forced the prime minister's
hand and led her to announce the snap
election in a televised address
i'd like to notify everyone after
listening to opinions from all sides
that i've decided to request a royal
decree to dissolve parliament this year
2013
the new election is set to take place at
the beginning of february
but the anti-government protesters say
the move does not go far enough
this is just another trick another lie
from the government because they're
still in charge everything in this
country they want to
they want to control totally control the
next election which means they're gonna
go back and corrupt again
i don't want the shinowat family here
anymore they should get out of the
country
the protesters accuse yingluck of
allowing her brother toxin to control
the government from exile he left the
country in 2006 after being overthrown
in a military coup
on sunday the main opposition democrat
party resigned from parliament on moss
saying they no longer wanted to
cooperate with shinawatra's government
it's unclear if they will contest or
boycott the new election